CHRISTMAS ABBOTT: In
my road, in my life.
I was [INAUDIBLE], and
I think that adolescence
is very influential.
I'd already been
smoking cigarettes
since I was nine,
kind of experimenting.
But I started regularly
smoking at the age of 13
because my parents smoked.
And so it was there.
It was easy access.
At 13, I also started
drinking excessively
and doing a lot
of drugs, whatever
I could get my hands on.
I didn't really care
about what it was.
I continued this lifestyle
all through my teens
and into my early 20s.
And during this time
in my early 20s,
my mother ended up
taking a job in Iraq
as a civilian contractor.
This was the first
time in history
that the civilians were
embedded with the military
for the operation
that they were doing.
So that was Operation
Iraqi Freedom.
And she kept telling
me, Christmas, this
is what you need to do.
You need to come over.
This is going to be an amazing
culture experience for you.
You'll be able to have some
money to pay for school.
And at the time, I
was working at a bar,
drinking excessively, doing
drugs, and having a party
lifestyle as a 21, 22-year-old
should-- or at least I thought.
[LAUGHTER]
And she recognized the
path that I was on,
and she was willing to put
me into an active war zone
to save my life.
That's a mama's love.
So I harassed the
company for six months.
I applied every week for six
months until they hired me.
And I got hired on as
a laundry attendant.
You brought me your laundry,
and I gave you a ticket,
and hopefully three
days later, it
came back clean and not lost.
We had a lot of claims.
So I went overseas in Iraq, and
this was actively a war zone.
So this is in
January 2004, where
we were just kind of getting
our feet on the ground.
You would think
that I was prepared.
You know, I quit drugs
enough to pass the drug test
and would sit in
class-- true story,
it's funny-- sit in class
and listen to what we
had to do when we had incoming.
And I know that I heard
what I was supposed to do,
but there was no
practical application,
so we didn't practice it.
I should have paid
attention a little closer.
Within the first two
weeks of being in country,
we had incoming, meaning
mortars or rockets
coming into your camp.
And the close-- it was
so close in proximity,
it was about 200-- it was
about 300 to 400 meters
from where I was sleeping.
And there are specific sounds
that you are familiar with,
and I didn't understand.
I didn't recognize
any of these sounds.
And so it's kind of like
when you're sleeping
and you hear a noise in
your house that's not right,
and the quietest noise will
take you out of a dead sleep.
This was my first
experience with incoming.
The boom and the
crash was deafening.
I immediately, knee-jerk
reaction, jumped out of bed,
landed on both my feet,
and looked around.
Did everything wrong.
I was supposed to
roll out of bed.
put on my Kevlar.
I was supposed to
radio in that I was OK.
Did everything absolutely wrong.
I'm standing there,
looking around.
And in this moment, I had
such a clear thought process.
It was grossly apparent
to me, a few things.
One, you always sleep with
clothes on in a war zone.
[LAUGHTER]
Two-- you've got to be
able to run fast. [LAUGHS]
Priorities happen.
And two, I recognized the
behaviors of my lifestyle
were setting me up to
end up killing myself.
And it sounds drastic
for me to declare that,
but that's absolutely
what went through my mind.
I thought, oh, my God.
I am going to die
of my own choices.
I was smoking, and civilians
had a different rule,
so I was also
drinking in country.
We had a bar that we could
bring our own bottle to.
And then three, I'm
in an active war zone,
and I'm still making
these really poor choices
about my lifestyle.
And it just-- it
came to me that I
needed to not necessarily become
a superhero fitness freak,
but I needed to make a
better decision for myself.
And that stemmed from my
desire of not wanting to die.
In life, wherever
you are, you're
either pushed away
from something
that you don't want
to be associated with,
or you're drawn toward something
that you want to emulate more.
And at this point in
my fitness pendulum,
it was the first step
to be pushing away
from that bad lifestyle of
choices, negative choices
that I was making.
It didn't happen overnight.
This was what we call
the awareness process, is
I was aware of the bad
choices that I was making,
so I finally wanted
to make a change.
And I had to build some
confidence to make that change.
It took me-- the first
thing that I decided to do
was to quit smoking.
And given I had almost
been smoking for a decade.
It was pretty-- yeah, regularly.
People were like, oh, you're 22.
You'll be fine.
Well, a decade is a
decade of bad behavior.
So I decided that I was
going to quit smoking.
It took me three months
to build my confidence
and to prepare
mentally for this.
Three months, and
I quit cold turkey.
I warned everybody.
I was like, look.
I'm just going to be a
raging B. Deal with it.
[LAUGHTER]
So I set everybody
up for success, OK?
Quit smoking.
A couple months later, I decided
that I was going to run a mile.
Because I hadn't done that
since I was in middle school,
and I was forced to, so I
really only did it-- like,
I kind of sped walked in order
to get a passing grade, barely.
And the smartest
thing that I did
was recruit a friend,
which was also
the stupidest thing that I did.
So we'd go into the gym.
And in Iraq, you
don't run outside.
You run on treadmills.
And on treadmills,
you can actually
set the pace where all you have
to do is pick up your feet.
Right?
It kind of works for you.
The beautiful thing
about treadmills.
And I decided I was going
to go run this mile.
So he ran his mile beside me.
He finished his mile.
And I was, like, halfway
through with mine.
And I was like,
this is-- I'm done.
I'm done.
And he was like, no, Christmas.
You have to finish.
You started this,
you finish this.
I was like, OK, fine.
Slow it down.
[LAUGHTER]
I ended up-- you know, you
could have walked the mile
that I ran that day.
I was 22 years old.
I wasn't grossly overweight.
I was actually
pretty underweight.
And I should have been
able to handle this.
I got off.
I hated him.
I was like, we're not
fitness friends anymore.
[LAUGHTER]
I went home, and it took
me a week to recover.
I hobbled around like a broken
little girl for a whole week.
And that was devastating.
So I was like, I hate fitness.
This is not for me.
I quit smoking, I'll eat some
grilled chicken, we're good.
So I was pretty discouraged with
any kind of exercise regimen,
because my first
experience was traumatic.
And I talk about this
especially for you
guys that are curious
about CrossFit,
because it's the
coach's responsibility
to make sure that they
water it down and put you
in the shallow end, that you
leave feeling successful,
and that you leave
wanting to come back.
Because I didn't want to go
back, and it was just a mile.
A mile.
[LAUGHS]
It's funny.
So I took a hiatus from any
kind of fitness whatsoever,
and then three months later, out
of pure boredom and harassment
from my friends
of being like, you
need to get in the
gym, Christmas,
you're eating too
many cheesecakes,
that I ended up going
to the gym again.
But I found the elliptical.
And I loved the elliptical.
I was good at the elliptical.
[LAUGHTER]
It's funny because it's true.
And people were
like, the elliptical?
Really, Christmas?
It was my gateway fitness drug.
I got on the elliptical,
and I was good.
So I'd pump.
And it was just something
that I could do passive.
You know, just get on there.
I got on there for 20, 30
minutes, couple days out
of the week, and it was it.
And I found the first
motivation of my life
where I would be there cruising.
And then of course
I'm in this, you know,
military area, and these
cute Marines would walk by,
and then I'd just
start pumping, right?
Motivation.
External motivation.
Cute boys make you
want to work hard.
[LAUGHTER]
And I'm just, like, sweating.
And as soon as they turn around
and walk away, I'm like, shit.
OK.
Oh, thank God they
turned around,
and I'd just almost stop.
It's like coaches perusing
the gym floor, you know?
As soon as your coach
comes by, you're
the best athlete in the world.
You're an Olympian.
[LAUGHTER]
They turn their back, and
you're like, I'm done.
I'm retired.
[LAUGHTER]
So that was the first
time that I ever
kind of wanted to apply myself.
And, yeah.
You know, cute people
are a good motivation.
But after a few weeks, I
saw a difference in my body.
It wasn't apparent.
It wasn't like, oh, my gosh.
I have, like, all
these biceps now.
It's crazy.
But it was just
something different.
My body felt different.
My clothes were
fitting different.
I was sleeping better.
And I was like, well,
this is kind of neat.
I like what's happening.
And then I found that my
real motivation was internal.
It was something
that I was doing
that was eliciting a
positive result to my body,
and ultimately my mental
and emotional state as well.
And that's when I
discovered that I really
love what I'm doing, and
I want to do it more.
So I was like, OK.
I love the elliptical.
What do we do with
these things over here?
And I had to literally
have somebody
take me around and tell
me what a dumbbell was.
And tell me--
because at that point
it was just all machines
and then free weights.
It wasn't this combination
of what I do now as CrossFit.
And they were like,
OK, Christmas.
It's like you guys
talking to somebody
that doesn't understand
any kind of IT stuff.
You're like, you
turn the computer on,
this is your mouse.
[LAUGHTER]
Very primitive explanation.
And I just got into it.
A couple months of really kind
of being consistent and really
loving what I see with
the changes in my body,
I discovered CrossFit.
And my friend was like,
you need to do this.
And I was like,
that-- I don't even
know what you're talking about.
He showed me a video.
It was these three girls
the same size as I am,
and they were getting after it.
They were doing things that
I'd never seen done before.
They were air squatting,
below parallel.
And they were doing these
cleans that I-- I was like,
they were lifting
such big weights
and then doing these
gymnastic things, muscle-ups.
And if you're
familiar with CrossFit
and you watch this
movie or this video,
make sure you Google
CrossFit nasty girls.
Make sure that that
CrossFit is in there.
[LAUGHTER]
Can't promise what else
you're going to find,
but you guys are smart
enough to figure it out.
OK?
And I loved it, because
these girls were my size,
they still were feminine.
Because at this time,
you were either a runner,
or you were a bodybuilder.
You either looked like you
needed to eat something,
or you look like you
just ate a runner.
[LAUGHTER]
There was no middle ground.
I didn't know.
And so I was like,
well, I kind of
don't want to be
either one of those,
and then here I found that these
girls were this middle ground,
and it was beautiful.
And they were teeny,
and they were badass.
And I was like, that's
what I want to do.
Because the girl cries at
the end, and I was like,
I want to do a workout
that makes me cry.
[LAUGHTER]
Be careful what you wish for.
This might be a little TMI,
but every year I do a workout
that-- sometimes several
times a year-- that
elicits, like, a crying.
But not because it's terrible,
but because your body
has reached its full
capacity physically
that you have no other release
other than an emotional cry.
And it's pretty incredible that
you can actually physically
push yourself to that level.
So I started doing CrossFit
on my own about a year,
and then I got into Baghdad
with some of these guys.
And these guys were
prior military.
The company that I worked
with was prior military,
all Special Forces.
So you're talking about
Marine recon, SEALs, Rangers,
I mean the alpha of the alpha.
And then here I am.
And I walk up to this guy.
I heard that there was one guy
in the camp that did CrossFit.
So I was like, hey.
I hear you do CrossFit.
And, you know, like,
testosterone is
an amazing thing.
(DEEP VOICE) Yeah.
I'm like, great.
I do CrossFit.
Can we CrossFit together?
(DEEP VOICE) Maybe.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
Turned around.
The next day, they
watched me try and do
this CrossFit workout,
Diane, which is handstand
push-ups and deadlifts.
My handstand push-ups were
like-- like, I was just, like,
raising the roof.
[LAUGHTER]
And I think I was
using 85 pounds
for the deadlift
with a prescribed--
or what's suggested
as 155 for women.
And it was atrocious.
I wouldn't have invited
me to work out at all.
I'm like, let that
girl by herself.
And I ended up-- they took me
into their group, but really
only to see how much I could
tolerate before I quit.
And little did they know
that I'm really stubborn.
[LAUGHS] And I kept coming back.
And they're the
ones that taught me,
like I was saying
earlier before,
is that once you start
something, you finish it.
You hold yourself
accountable to your actions.
So you apply integrity, and
you always, always just keep
your head high.
There's no other option
other than to finish.
And I took that into not only
my workouts, but my life's work
with my gym, my relationships,
and my businesses.
And that's where I've really
been able to thrive and find
success.
And success isn't because you're
instantly good at something.
I was terrible, OK?
10 years in, you
eventually find your niche.
[LAUGHTER]
But it was through
failure after failure
after failure-- and my
hashtag is relentlesslife
because I refused to quit.
I refused to give up.
And it's through that due
diligence that I found success.
I finally got a muscle-up.
I finally was able to
deadlift over 200 pounds.
I was finally able to
build my own business.
I was finally able to write
my own nutrition seminar,
and have the confidence
to go out and teach it.
I was finally able
to write my own book
and now dictate my own schedule.
[LAUGHS]
Right?
And it's because of those guys
that I have such gratitude for.
So one small soap box that
I always kind of include
in whatever kind
of talk that I do
is that the servicemen
of our country
don't decide where they
go and why they go there.
They just execute
somebody else's command.
So please support your troops.
And they're the
reason that we're
able to sit here and
talk about it today.
So I came home, and
through force, my friend
told me that I needed to
apply and do a competition.
And I was like, no.
I'm not an athlete.
I'm not a competitor.
I just like to CrossFit.
He was like, no, Christmas.
You're going.
I'm driving you there.
I'm entering you.
Just go have a good time.
And I was like, I hate you.
Fine.
But I'm only going to have fun.
I'm not going to apply myself.
And he was like, OK, great.
I went, and the
first workout I'm,
like, waving to my friends.
And they're like, Christmas, go.
You're supposed
to be working out.
And I'm like, I'm
supposed to be having fun.
[LAUGHTER]
But the point of that is that
he wanted me to try something.
I didn't want to do it.
I had already this
preconceived notion
of what I was going
to experience.
I knew that I wasn't
going to like it.
I knew I wasn't a competitor.
But he was like, just do it.
And I did it.
And then this magical
thing happened.
This little monster
inside of me woke up,
and it wanted to eat souls.
It wanted to win.
You know?
And it wasn't against one
person, but it was for myself.
I wanted to show myself what I
was truly capable of in hitting
my true potential.
And that's magical.
And that can be applied
not just to fitness,
but to your own life's work.
And since then-- I still
call it my little monster.
But something happens on
that competition floor
or when I'm approached with any
kind of competition situation,
or like where I need to
excel and do my best.
That little monster
wakes up, and there
is nothing else that is
between me and that goal
other than myself.
You know, like, how
bad do I want this?
And it's a beautiful,
beautiful thing.
And I thank him all
the time for that.
He's actually my business
partner with Invoke now.
Same thing happened
when I got into NASCAR.
I was duped.
They called me and they
were like, hey, Christmas.
You want to come play NASCAR?
They said play NASCAR.
And I was like, yeah.
I'm going to drive
some fast cars.
You know?
Assumed.
[LAUGHS] I got there,
and they were like,
we're going to do this
pit crew challenge,
and you're going
to change a tire.
And I was like, mm-mm.
[LAUGHTER]
No.
I knew-- I had that
preconceived conviction
of what was going to happen.
I knew that I wasn't
going to like it,
even though I never
experienced it.
And they were like, OK.
And I was there.
I had already driven all the
way over there, three hours.
And I'm like, well,
I can't just bounce.
And I was like, I'll go in and
then find a reason to leave.
And as soon as I heard
what was going on,
I saw this crazy orchestra
of people and chaos,
and I was like, (WHISPERING)
I want to be in there.
Can I go play?
They're like, that's what
you're going to be doing today,
Christmas.
And I was like, well,
why didn't you tell me
we were going to have fun?
[LAUGHTER]
And I did it, and I loved it.
Beat the boys.
And the hand speed of
a NASCAR Sprint Cup--
so that's the highest
level you can go.
That's what you
actually see on TV.
And a standard hand speed is
1.2 seconds for five lug nuts.
That's pretty-- and you have
to have, like, accuracy.
It's all-- I could geek out
about that for another three
hours.
It's intense.
And my hand speed that
day was 1.7 seconds.
So I was only half
a second from being
at the highest level first day
I tried it, fourth attempt.
I got a call two weeks later.
They were like, hey, you
want to come play NASCAR?
And I was like, do I
get to change tires?
They were like, yes.
I was like, I'm there.
[LAUGHTER]
So I made-- I
jumped through hoops
to make it work to where I
could pursue this interest.
And I had no intention on
what it was really happening.
I thought I was just going
to go play NASCAR for a year
and kind of experience
it and then go back home.
But the reason I
didn't say no is
because, one, I just-- I had
such an obsession with it
the same way I had an
obsession with CrossFit,
and it had been so good to me.
And I just wanted to try it.
So I started to not
say no and say yes,
even though my life
didn't exactly permit it.
It wasn't saying, hey, you
have nothing else to do.
Go play NASCAR.
I forged it into my life.
And you know, had a lot of
great benefits from that.
The point of this
is that there is
going to be a lot of things
that come up in your life
that you are certain,
without a doubt, conviction,
that you do not
like, or you know
that you're not
going to appreciate,
or you know you're
not going to enjoy.
And I ask you to
challenge yourself
to reserve that thought or that
experience until you try it.
You don't know until you try it.
And I know that we always
hear that, but the few things
that I was certain in my
life that I did not like--
and I'd even tried one
and I didn't like it.
Running-- fitness
was not for me.
But those are the
few things that
actually changed the
entire course of my life
and made me a better
person, and cultivated
this positive lifestyle
that I live today.
So before you knock
it, you better
try it, because you don't
know if that is going
to be a fork in your road.
Or at least then, you can
have an educated decision
or an educated
experience on that topic.
And you can say with
conviction and experience
that you don't like it.
Peanut butter on eggs.
It's delicious.
Don't scrunch your
nose at me, baby.
You haven't tried it yet.
[LAUGHTER]
Anyway, so I say this talking
about food because people--
you know, they look at the diet
regimen and they're like, no.
I'm not going to like that.
That isn't going to work.
Well, have you tried it?
Did you apply yourself?
Did you give it a certain
amount of time period
to educate yourself and
have that experience?
Probably not.
So before you say no and
close the door on something
that could be absolutely
amazing, then at least go in,
and you haven't
really lost much.
It won't derail your life to
give something a little try.
Unless you're going to go,
like, base jumping or something.
That might be a little
bit more adventurous
than a diet regimen.
So I just ask and
beg of that of you.
And that's really-- I like
to dive into my background.
The reason the book
was created was
because I just got-- I
kept getting questions
on my diet regimen.
And I have experimented
with myself
on diet regimens
for years and years.
And that's how this
was created, was
it was cherry-picked from other
diet regimens that I tried.
And I took what I liked,
left what I didn't, and I've
been practicing this
for 10 years as well.
Eventually, I got tired of
answering emails, created
the nutrition seminar, and from
there, the book was spawned.
So there you have the book.
Thank you so much for listening.
You guys were-- you
laughed at my jokes.
So I appreciate that.
Sometimes people don't and
I'm just kind of up here,
entertaining myself.
[LAUGHTER]
I know that we didn't
talk much about the food,
but if you do nothing
else, just take
the foundation of balancing
your protein, carbohydrates,
and fats.
Educate yourself
on what they are.
It's in the book.
And then emphasizing that on
the quality scale of the premium
foods versus acceptable foods
versus really bad foods.
And if you do nothing else
but to kind of balance
those three-- every meal,
every snack, that triplet,
that trifecta with a
balance of the food scale,
then you're going to be leaps
and bounds better than somebody
else.
That was me getting
on the elliptical.
If you want to get into
the food CrossFit concept,
then weigh and
measure and dial it
in for approximately
three weeks.
You don't have to
do it all the time.
I barely ever weigh and
measure my food now anymore,
because I've been
applying this for so long
that it's second
nature to me now.
It will get easier.
I promise.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
First question?
Let's go.
AUDIENCE: So it sounds
like you advocated
balancing your macros per meal.
I usually hear of people
balancing it like per day.
You know, like IIFYM, et cetera.
Anything you can
say about trying
it one way versus the other?
CHRISTMAS ABBOTT: Pfft.
It's like I set this up for you.
I love it.
So balancing your
macros per meal
is going to a elicit a
positive hormonal response
and keep you balanced
throughout the day.
Versus if you balance your
macros throughout the day,
you can still have a carb
overload and an insulin
response to foods, so
your hormonal response
is going up and down.
Versus if you couple
it for every meal,
it's going to keep that hormonal
response in the same layer.
Does that make sense?
So I love the concept of
balanced macros per day,
but I like to break
it down even further.
Because you can still
have some major health
issues if you're spiking your
insulin on a daily basis.
AUDIENCE: So it sounds like
that applied more to the carbs
than to the protein versus fat.
CHRISTMAS ABBOTT:
You know, the carbs
are really the dominant
hormonal response that kind of
is what people struggle with.
It's what we want most, right?
I mean, a recovering
heroin addict
doesn't walk around
with grilled chicken.
It walks around with
sugar and sweets.
It makes us feel good,
which is why we love it.
So isolating that,
then it's going
to be much more disruptive than
your proteins and your fats.
However, they work
best together.
It's like this trifecta, this
team of three or triplets
that you really don't
want to separate.
They work in a good synergy
together versus separated.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
CHRISTMAS ABBOTT: Thank you.
That's like the first
time that nobody's ever
hesitated on asking a question,
especially in the front row.
[LAUGHTER]
Only at Google.
I love it. [LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
was just curious on--
so whenever you first
started working out,
it sounded like the
way your body looked
and your fitness kind of went
hand in hand on the same road.
But I'm kind of
curious on the way you
see CrossFit women going a lot.
They're getting, like, bigger
and stronger-- which is fine.
But my--
[LAUGHTER]
You're not big.
But what would you say
whenever those roads start
to diverge where, say, a woman
wants to look a certain way,
but if she wants to
get better at CrossFit,
and you can't do both,
what would you say to that?
CHRISTMAS ABBOTT:
You know, that's
such a-- people get so
wrapped up into this.
My body has changed tremendously
over the last 10 years,
but I'm still very petite.
I actually still wear
the same size of clothes
that I did when I
started CrossFit.
So my clothes didn't change.
Just my bubbly body did change.
And often we see the CrossFit
Games, which just happened.
We see the female competitors
of the CrossFit Games,
and they are the exception.
They are the 1% of
CrossFitters that
are going to go to the games.
They made their training
and their food regimen
in order to be able to
perform at a certain level.
It is the same thing
for any other sport.
It's a specialty.
They are at the top
of the pyramid there.
Where women generally
look at, they're like, oh,
I don't want to CrossFit because
I don't want to get bulky.
And they see the
CrossFit Games athletes,
who are beautiful bodied because
their body-- they're demanding
work of their body, and that's
the response that they're
eliciting is the
aesthetics, right?
So I think what
you're asking is women
that want to have a little
bit of a leaner frame,
but they want to be badass
in Crossfit-- right? [LAUGHS]
Yeah.
You're going to-- over time,
that psychological aspect is
going to change for a female.
They're going to get stronger,
but not get super bulky.
So as soon as they
start to realize
that they can keep their
aesthetics pretty close to what
they started with,
with a little bit more,
like, abs and nice
butt, you know,
like, it's just a good
response, that they are just
going to keep this nice,
slim, but muscular look
without looking like
a Games competitor.
I am the strongest that
I've ever been in my life,
but I still keep
a very sleek body.
And it's not changing
my workout regimen.
You can change your
workout regimen
to appeal to the aesthetics
that you're looking for.
But I just tell
people to keep lifting
and to keep doing the
workouts, and allow your body
to work for you.
It's amazing what we
can push our bodies to.
And the byproduct is a
gorgeous, muscular body.
They won't get to that level
unless it's intentional.
Same thing as like
a bodybuilder.
You can go in and do
curls, bicep extensions.
You're not going to look
like Arnold Schwarzenegger
unless you start pumping
things into your body that
are-- shouldn't be
pumping into, right?
[LAUGHTER]
And I'm not saying that CrossFit
athletes at the highest level
do that rampantly, but they
change their entire lifestyle
to get that-- not look,
but that performance.
So really, I just tell them to
keep doing what they're doing,
and they'll be OK.
They'll survive.
And if they start getting
to a point where they think
that they're a
little bit larger,
then you can change
the programming
to complement the
aesthetic that they want.
It's really in their control.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So what is your
current training regimen like?
CHRISTMAS ABBOTT: Well, carrying
my suitcase through the airport
right now.
[LAUGHTER]
But it depends on
the time of the year.
Right now I'm preparing
for nationals,
which is a weightlifting
competition in August.
And so I'm doing a
lot of weight lifting,
a lot of explosive
power movements,
and just trying to get
my lifting numbers up.
And when I go home, I'll
train six days a week
and do two to three
workouts each of those days.
During my off season,
I only attend class.
One day-- you know,
like, once a day, I just
do the class workout.
So I personally, I ebb
and flow the workload
because I want to be able
to be in my 80s or 90s
and chasing my grandchildren.
The shelf life of a competitive
athlete is very, very short.
And you're seeing this kind
of-- even happening this year,
you know, Annie
Thorisdottir was injured,
and she had to bow out.
Look how long she
reigned supreme
before you start seeing injuries
at that high of a level.
And I prefer to have a longevity
in my athletic career versus be
the top for three years.
So it ebbs and flows.
AUDIENCE: So in that
two to three days,
are you doing, like, strength
training in the morning, then
your CrossFit-style workouts,
like, your intensity
intervals at night?
CHRISTMAS ABBOTT:
You know, I don't
like to go to the
gym twice in a day.
And so what I
normally will do is
in an hour-- now it's taking
about two hours or so-- I'll go
and I'll do a weight
lifting component, just
some kind of a complex.
And then I do a
strength component.
And after that,
I'll do auxiliary.
So it's kind of like a
sled push and GHD sit-ups,
something to really
get me gassed.
And then at the end, I'll do
some mobility, stabilizing.
And that's pretty
standard or skill work.
That's pretty standard
for at least twice a week.
That volume is very
difficult for me,
because I just don't
need the volume anymore.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHRISTMAS ABBOTT: Thank you.
I like the technical questions.
[LAUGHS]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you
so much for being here.
CHRISTMAS ABBOTT: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: There's
books in the back.
[APPLAUSE]